un très clairement moi en fait après mes
études j'ai un peu prier je vais pas
appeler ça un job alimentaire parce que
ça correspondait un petit peu à ce que
je faisais en marketing mais c'était un
job qui n'était pas très très bien
rémunérés et gémit quand même deux mois
avant de trouver donc il ya eu deux mois
de chômage
et encore j'ai eu la chance d'avoir le
chômage parce que j'avais fait un ans
d'alternance mais sinon je vais du tout
vous êtes originaire de la réunion et je
lis vous êtes partir 13 ans oui j'ai
quitté mon foyer familial à 13 ans pour
aller où elle étudia na waie voilà c'est
ça donc j'ai fait énormément de
sacrifices de voir que à l'heure
actuelle je suis là c'est ça c'est une
déception oui c'est une énorme déception
suite c'est vrai que pour ma part marié
mlc dit je suis parti j'ai réussi parce
que dans l'un sur vos parents vos
proches étaient très fiers de vous sont
liées à la vie elle a réussi justement à
à faire des études et elle se retrouve
sans rien et quand vous envoyer des cv
vous avez envoyé plus de centaines
plusieurs centaines de cv non mais j'ai
très peu de réponses très peu de
réponses
et quand il ya des réponses c'est
quasiment toutes en négative à wimax et
ça donc
mais et c'est vrai que c'est ce que
disait tout à l'heure bérénice
aujourd'hui ça marche au piston une de
rien madame la ministre nous le mentorat
oui d'où le mentorat c'est le réseau des
gens qui n'ont pas de réseau oui je
pense que c'est important et il serait
assez c est en tout cas enfin vous avez
un parcours super brillant me vraiment
bravo je pense qu'on peut vous applaudir
c'est vrai que j'avais réellement garcia
les 10 à m mais le problème c'est que
elle elle et elle est fière d'elle elle
est fière de son parcours
mais aujourd'hui pour le quotidien c'est
une catastrophe parce qu'elle est dans
le rouge est arrivé
non mais c'est vrai vous êtes dans le
rouge oui bah oui et donc c'est une
tannée tous les jours quoi abattre tous
les jours je stresse falloir tous les
mois plus tôt quand la rue parce que
j'ai en fait j'ai un prêt étudiant à
rembourser aussi rencontre n'est pas du
tout évident donc j'ai ça j'ai mon loyer
j'ai toutes les charges en tout ça
s'accumule et vu que actuellement bas on
va dire j'ai la chance d'être en stage
donc j'ai un revenu fixe mais qui est
très faible vous en doutez parce que des
entreprises qui prennent en stage elles
font ce qu'elles peuvent donc elle donne
mais très peu et là mes droits pâle en
place sont finies donc clairement
j'aurais aimé pioneer quelqu'un qui vous
aide dans votre recherche d'emploi vous
êtes rapprocher par exemple d'une
mission locale noyer ses amis sont
normales j'aime la paix cléon on parlait
de l'association pour l'emploi des
cadres
mais je suis même à une asso qui
s'appelle la haine qu tu es qui aide je
te même que de jouer mentorat
mais malgré tout ça bon j'ai une super
marraine qui m'aide beaucoup dans mes
recherches mais sinon c'est vrai que
c'est très compliqué on va dire que
entre guillemets j'ai pas besoin d'être
dans ma recherche d'emploi parce que je
feins dans le parcours que j'ai eus je
sais faire un cv je sais faire une
lettre de motivation je sais me
présenter en entretien j'estime que j'ai
vraiment des qualités qui sont
recherchés dans dans le marché du
travail et j'ai fait aussi une
alternance parce que je voulais avoir
c'est une expérience soit l'expérience
et je vois que même avec tout ça il n'y
a rien qui se bat alors justement j'ai
une question pour vous parce que c'est
ce que comprend pas aussi marine
pourquoi la barre des 25 ans pour le rsa
parce qu'il ya plein de jeunes voilà qui
ont qui sont requis entre 18 et 25 ans
qui sont en galère et qui n'ont pas de
parents pour les aider et qui se
retrouvent sans rien ils se retrouvent à
la rue et essai et j'en vois de plus en
plus ce qui passe dans l'émission
pourquoi oui je vous dise c'est mieux
500 euros par mois et on est là vous
savez c'est vrai moi j'avais zéro donc
ils sont obligés de trouver des petits
boulots
voilà donc alors moi j'ai pas de doute
et je pense que tous les jeunes qui sont
là en témoignent bien évidemment quand
il ya des jeunes qui sont dans une
galère financière il faut les aider
donc il faut pouvoir leur donner une
allocation on peut pas uniquement donner
une allocation je pense que vous le
dites vous voulez pas avoir simplement
500 euros par mois puis qu'on vous aide
pas davantage à trouver un vrai job ça
peut être si on tient en fait
en attendant de trouver l'emploi parce
que la mise en place de ce rsa va aider
plus de jeunes aujourd'hui qui sont dans
le rouge et le fait de mettre en place
c'est pas dit aux jeunes ne faisais même
on veut faire mieux ça fait ça veut
faire mieux et quand on voit les
politiques en place du rsa on supprime
des jeunes
alors je dois en faire partie parce que
voilà et oui en fait partie c'est
vraiment moi je veux insister sur le
fait qu' on veut faire mieux c'est à
dire qu'on veut effectivement aider les
jeunes qui ne s'en sortent pas
financièrement avec une aide financière
une allocation qui leur donne de la
visibilité et en même temps leur donner
un soutien un accompagnement les aider à
bâtir un projet professionnel et on voit
que c'est pas forcément évident vouloir
mieux avant de fermer les universités
d'enfermer les étudiants chez eux sur
leur écran à regarder les courses
étaient avant qu'il fallait faire mais
en fait moi je pense que le mal et les
faits déjà la planète elle est déjà
crevé en fait maintenant c'est histoire
de voir si on va juste faire ça bien
ensemble est-ce qu'on va continuer de se
se mordre par derrière et faire des
trucs qui sont pas cool on va en voir
servie d'un quotidien cela n'était pas
du tout envie de me revendiquer de me
montrer en quoi j'ai même endroit plus
envie de me cacher jusqu'à tient plutôt
réservés mais rassembler les gens c'est
un cadeau en fait de dingue
il ya deux jours les bars étaient
ouverts on a rassemblé les gens on a
fait la fête comme des fous et tout
s'est très bien passé il n'y a pas eu un
seul blessé
sauf que si en fait quand les policiers
sont venus pour taper sur les gens pour
les faire rentrer chez eux
là il ya eu des blessés et ça s'est
passé dans le centre-ville dans les
centre-villes même pas dans la campagne
mais pas caché devant les caméras donc
elles savent à quoi ces caméras en fait
donc je comprends que vous vous demandez
pourquoi on avait fermé les terrasses
oui oui c'était pour nom mais en fait
moi les avis religieux les virus
peut-être les étudiants n'arrivent plus
à se rencontrer sur les dons
hamma montaigne la fac de bordeaux pour
animer un petit peu on a servi de la
nourriture voilà c'est pour la précarité
étudiante aussi il ya des étudiants en
fait ils sont arrivés à la fac ils ont
pas rencontré un seul jeune de l'année
on était en en est parfaitement
conscient sur cyberpresse ça donc oui il
y en a qui se suicident en fait il en
est parfaitement conscient c'est
l'histoire de débats c'est pas des
choses à dire c'est des choses à faire
allez on est parfaitement conscient que
c'est une année qui a été très dur pour
tout le monde et particulièrement pour
les jeunes il faut aussi qu'on protège
les français face à la cohue vide et
c'est pour ça qu'on a accéléré la
campagne de vaccination donc vous avez
vu qu'à partir du 31 mai tout le monde
pour aller se faire vacciner
on a déjà vacciné plus de 20 millions de
personnes et grâce à ça on va s'en
sortir et on a tous envie de reprendre
une vie normale mais il est parfaitement
conscient des sacrifices qui ont été
demandés après après je vous dire après
c'est pareil dans de nombreux pays les
fusées il ya des jeunes qui se
relèveront jamais c'est vrai de s'est
passé alors juste avant qu'on écoute
bérénice également puisque ça va être à
bout je voudrais dire que pour marième
j'ai un mentor et on a un mentor
exceptionnelle pour vous est ce que je
demande d'accueillir véronique morali
[Musique]
on commence à voir des routes
tag honneur pour moi de te voir alors
véronique elle est exceptionnelle non
mais vraiment c'est que j'aime beaucoup
voilà j'aime beaucoup ce qu'elle fait
elle est présidente du directoire de
webedia et là c'est un mentor
exceptionnel qu'on me propose marième ce
soir vous allez le moteur de mariée mme
véronique et ben c'est un grand plaisir
d'abord d'être là dans cette émission
parce que c'est une initiative qu'on
soutient j'aurais voulu être là avec
cédric siré donc j'adore je sais que
vous connaissez aussi avec tous les co
dirigent ou abélia et webedia c'est une
entreprise de jeunes on est deux mille
jeunes de haut
j'ai pour vous mettre dedans non d'abord
facile voilà les locaux communiquent la
présence de tous ces jeunes chez nous
c'est quelque chose où d'une part c'est
une entreprise où nous on considère que
pas john pas de solution si je voudrais
je voulais caricaturer ses vrais formule
parce que c'est une source d'inspiration
parce que c'est en permanence une
ouverture sur la vie et quelles que
soient les difficultés très grande et le
côté même assez tragique de certaines
situations on confronte tous les jours
on a envie d'aider et c'est pour ça
qu'on est là et que avec cédric qu'on
avait très envie d'aider marianne
d'abord parce que elle elle souhaite
travailler dans un dans un domaine dans
un univers qui est le nôtre
j'ai vu que tu as fait une spécialité eu
x oui oui mais au delà du marketing
digital
nous on a des tas d'os paul puisqu'on
les visites des sites comme allociné
jeuxvideo.com 750 g
donc c'est quand même un univers donc a
mon avis tu vas t'y plaire et vous savez
on a une surprise alors bien sûr un
manteau ring on va t'accompagner du
mieux qu'on le peut mais on voulait te
proposer un cdd de six mois
dès que ton stage sera finie donc on a
compris à partir de juillet moi j'ai
écouté et cédric et toute l'équipe la rh
de webedia donc voyage que j'ai trouvé
très digne très posé tout en retenue en
sobriété et je trouve ça assez
formidable dans la galère dans laquelle
tu ne débatte d'être capable d'articuler
tonton présent mais aussi ton avenir et
thérèse
donc on avait très envie d'y répondre et
puis en plus c'est une super championne
de tennis on a vu au nez moi aussi je
vais me mettre appel d'offres de 3
raquettes et de boîtes de balles voilà
exactement donc on est très heureux
[Applaudissements]
bourahli résidents du lac albert
cédric siré et toutes les décisions et
les dates c'est un travail formidable
que j'adore voilà qui sont combien
et là tu es heureuse la marée on dirait
moi quand j'ai vu michou j'étais comme
un fou que ça rigole et ben voilà bah
merci merci merci
on n'est pas tant la révolution à
marianne parce que vos témoignages
il nous a vraiment ému et je sais que tu
vois là tu voulais absolument t'en
sortir dans la vie tu es partie de ces
très jeunes devant la brutalité et que
tes parents et c'est que j'espère qu'on
va pouvoir te donner un coup de pouce ce
soir